lily good to see you
good to see you thank you for talking to
me
congratulations on this i love the the
photo you posted of everybody together
at south by for the premiere
and you called nicholas cage and i post
king cage do you call him king cage to
his face
i mean
to his face i'm nervous to even say nick
i want to be like i defer you know he's
so he is genuinely king cage i want to
be as respectful as possible i'm sure he
would tell me i'm being silly about that
but he's like the nicest person alive
he'd be like why are you doing that but
he's i wish
and one of the things this movie
highlights is like
the perspectives that nicholas cage fans
have of nicholas h based on the movies
that he's done but in your experience
with him working on set with him like
what is the difference between the nic
cage that you got on set and the cage
that a lot of people see on screen
i mean what's so cool about about him is
that he goes 100 into every character
that he's doing and so
what i felt really lucky to be able to
witness was him going full into this
kind of version of himself you know and
i'm sure for him it must have been you
know on a level therapeutic so
i did get to see him
you know being the most hyper nic cage
version of himself that he could
possibly be
um but then off camera he's just like
this lovely smart cinephile he's
obsessed with movies all he wants to do
is talk about movies and
i also want to talk about movies so i
was very lucky to do that but like i
mean if you like nick cage you're gonna
love the real nick cage you know what i
mean
yeah that's awesome is there a you know
if you could co-star with him
in any of his classic movies
you want to like which one would you
pick and who would you be
i mean this is very difficult because
this is very difficult
um i'm a huge wicker man fan i would
love to be one of the one of the
deranged villagers in the wicker man um
just to witness him kind of spiraling
into madness i think that would be
amazing but i don't want to
i think everyone is fantastic all the
movies he's done like i mean you can't
cast them better so you know
in a pinch uh
if you're going to say to someone that
you prefer which movie is it the cabinet
of dr caligari or paddington 2.
oh
this is the most difficult question
you've ever asked
probably honestly it sucks because you
know i'm supposed to be in this movie
going i hate caligari i hate all these
old movies and i actually really love
them so i will probably have to choose
caligari but
in in you know
in honor of my character i will say
paddington too
uh okay well look look i appreciate the
honesty because the thing is too
you know
i love the idea of you guys off camera
talking about movies and talking about
your favorite movies so this must have
been
on so many levels just such an amazing
experience for you it was incredible i
mean again like i think people can see
it such a like movie lovers movie and a
nick cage lovers movie and so because
i'm both of those things it felt like
kind of fitting into this amazing like
patchwork
um and it was great this is my first
movie so
i felt like i was very lucky to be able
to be working with all these actors who
are like at the absolute top of their
game being fantastic and very
professional and i got to learn from
them so it was fun and it was also like
an incredible lesson for me
yeah you know your mom is super proud of
you i saw what she had posted um
who was more excited about the prospect
of co-starring in a movie together you
were her
i mean you mean in the future
potentially yeah yeah oof that's tough i
mean if we were to co-star in a movie
together i would probably like it to be
something where we get to play
you know i get to play mother and she
gets to play daughter i want to flip the
script so maybe let's say i'm more
interested in that than her but you know
we'll see what happens
awesome awesome well hey i love this
movie i thought it was so much fun you
were great in it uh thank you so much
for the time
thank you so much
you